bonjour bienvenue dans le meilleur de
ses caches aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de cette crise mondiale qui nous
attend
il n'y a pas seulement les états qui
sont endettés ya aussi les ménages et
les entreprises
en france la dette immobilière ses 1300
milliards d'euros et un taux moyen le
taux moyen de calculer au mois de
septembre sur le toutes les échéances et
1,18 pour s'en servir c'est un taux très
bas donc les taux zéro il se retrouve
aussi à ce niveau là et ça veut dire que
ça pose des problèmes pour les banques
donc le fait d'avoir beaucoup de dette
qui devient insupportable pour les états
et des taux d'intérêts normaux donc ça
oblige les banques centrales à passer à
des taux zéro ça a des répercussions sur
les autres acteurs économiques alors
ceux qu'empruntent ils ont l'impression
de faire une bonne affaire même si en
fait ils payent l'immobilier plus cher
ce sacré une bulle immobilière mais mais
pour les banques ça pose un vrai
problème ça écrase leurs marges
d'intérêt et pour l'assurance vie
ça fait des rendements qui tombe qui
tendent vers zéro et donc ça provoque
aussi des problèmes pour les assureurs
donc la dette de l'état il faut pas la
voir de façon isolée
c'est un problème pour les tables et
c'est aussi un problème pour toute
l'économie est ce qu'un tel endettement
peut éventuellement nous mener vers une
nouvelle crise oui c'est à dire qu'à
partir d'un moment je crois que là le
prêtre de l'endettement il faut passer à
l'étape d'après c'est à dire que
maintenant on sait que la dette ne sera
pas remboursé il ya tel niveau de dette
publique écrivait dans le monde qui ont
atteint des niveaux délirants et donc la
joute l'étape d'après c'est là la fuite
de voir la monnaie c'est à dire que les
acteurs économiques vont commencer à
avoir des craintes vis-à-vis de la
monnaie elle même et ça on commence à le
voir parce que les discours des banques
centrales maintenant ils appuient la
même autorité qu'ils avaient avant on
voit que la fed la banque centrale
américaine avait commencé à remonter ses
taux et à diminuer son bilan c'est à
dire à revenir à une situation normale
donc on pouvait se dire on va revenir à
quelque chose de sain et à une économie
saine et puis en fait non on l'a fait l
affaire a pris un virage
l art baisser ses taux elle a commencé à
augmenter son bilan à faire une sorte de
de quantitative easing et donc à
racheter de la dette d'état et dans le
même temps on voit que la banque
centrale du japon elle n'a jamais arrêté
sont en quantité visite et que la banque
centrale européenne elle n'a aucune
intention de le faire est la nouvelle
présidente christine lagarde la partie
semble le faire donc les tout le monde
se rend compte maintenant que les
banques centrales en quelque sorte perdu
la main et peuvent faire revenir sains
situation économique normal et donc ça
je crois que l'étape d'après c'est que
les gens vont se dire mais que va voir
l'euro que va voir le dollar comme l'or
le yen
mais c'est quoi pour vous l'étape
d'après mais c'est ça c'est que on était
dans un modèle donc maintenant on ne
pouvait pas sortir
c'est à dire que vous êtes obligés de
rajouter de la dette à la dette regardez
le japon c'est 7 à 10% déficit
budgétaire par an donc la bête elle est
à 250 elle sera 268 278 300 puis à
bombay ça n'a pas de fin et pour
soutenir cette dette pour que justement
les taux d'intérêt de monde pas qu'est
ce que fait la banque du japon bat
quantitative easing sur quantitative
easing c'est à dire que l achète toute
la dette parce que plus personne n'en
veut évidemment puisque tout le monde
sait que ça ne sera jamais remboursé et
donc c'est elle qui se met en face
d'aidé de l'état japonais et qui
achètent absolument tout la bête et vous
voyez systématiquement quand monsieur qu
roda l'a fait plusieurs fois il est il
est venu devant les financiers en leur
disant ben voilà on va on va acheter un
peu moins on va essayer normaliser le
bilan au moment où la fed
disait qu'elle allait le faire et puis
tout de suite qui se passait les taux
remonter et puis là quand vous avez de
150% de n'être évidemment les taux qui
remonte d'eux mêmes de 0,2 ou 0,3 ça
fait mal et donc il se précipite et
d'ibm et vous même des très très mal
compris je vais continuer et plus que
jamais et c'est donc vous êtes rentré
dans un système dont vous ne pouvez plus
sortir et vous êtes obligés d'acheter
toujours plus et d'acheter tout ce qui
se présente parce que dès que les taux
montent c'est fini pendant très
longtemps les deux tiers la dette
publique française étaient étaient
détenues par les investisseurs
internationaux et seulement un tiers en
france ce qui posait un problème parce
que ça ne vous rendent est dépendant du
contexte international même si la la la
dette française a bonne presse
bon voilà et là ça a changé sans les
investisseurs internationaux font plus
qu'un peu plus de la moitié et il ya un
acteur qui est apparue et qui en détient
20% c'est la banque de france alors ça
peut sembler terme en fait non c'est un
résultat direct du quantitative easing
initié par la banque centrale européenne
mais qui est mis en oeuvre dans chaque
pays par les banques centrales et donc
la banque de france et donné un nouvel
acteur qui achètent de la dette ce qui
contribue à faire baisser les taux
d'intérêts saillard il ya une
augmentation de de la demande de dette
donc ça ça fait baisser les taux et donc
pour l'état cc c'est tout bénef parce
que ils payent des intérêts alors qu'ils
sont faibles mais ils payent des
intérêts sur la dette
mais il ya 20% ces deux de ses intérêts
qu'il verse à la banque de france la
banque de france à l'effet des revenus
donc des bénéfices et ses bénéfices sont
reversés à l'état voilà donc la banque
de france est devenu le nouvel acteur
sur ces dernières années mais je n'ai
rien de plus à dire c'est tout à fait ce
qui se passe mais le la part la part
détenue par par la bce ou par la banque
de france peu importe mais la part
détenue par la banque centrale va
augmenter ses mécaniques puisqu'ils ont
dit que on ne sortirait pas de cette
histoire de quantitative easing que
alors aujourd'hui il est limité mais il
est limité parce que
et
ils peuvent pas faire plus il est limité
parce que de fait il n'y a rien à
acheter
donc toutes les toutes les obliques qui
sont intéressantes et qui sont de bonne
qualité reste dans les bilans des
assureurs notamment et des banquiers et
le don qui a rien à trouver à l'achat
sur le marché donc ils n'ont pas besoin
de faire des quantitative easing 2 85
milliards 150 milliards dhs parce que il
trouve rien déjà quand il y avait 60
milliards par mois
il trouvait pas suffisamment à acheter
et ils se mettaient à acheter et ça ça
va être très nouveau c'est à dire que
ils se mettent à acheter aujourd'hui des
corporels c'est à dire des obligations
d'entreprises alors au départ salle et
c'est toujours la même chose vous
achetez vous achetez du très très bon
sauf que le très très bon vous le vend
pas c'est les assureurs qui les
détiennent par exemple et ils n'ont pas
du tout l'intention de les lâcher et
mais petit à petit vous abaissez vos
prétentions et vous vous mettez à
acheter des mobiles plus ou moins
pourriez donc on va avoir des banques
centrales qui vont être des gros et fun
avec des obligations pourries dedans
mais comment est-ce qu'on sort de la
dette
donc c'est bien leur problème hein c'est
on n'en sort pas et vous êtes vous êtes
sur une pente en plus ce qui est
ahurissant entre vous regardé aux états
unis pour vous donner une idée si vous
prenez dette de l'état et dette des
ménages aux états unis en 1980 vous
aviez une dette qui représentait tout
compris une dette qui représentait 79 %
du revenu médian des américains d'accor
là aujourd'hui vous êtes à plus de 600 %
c'est-à-dire 30 ans plus tard vous êtes
à plus de 600 % du revenu médian des
américains c'est un truc de fou et vous
voyez aujourd'hui que les états unis
systématiquement depuis depuis 2008 on
va dire je ne parle là que de la dette
de l'état mais en gros met entre trois
et quatre dollars pour avoir un dollar
de pipe de plus tous les ans d'accord
donc ça veut dire un endettement qui se
retrouvent croître de 1000 à 1500
milliards
tous les ans alors évidemment vous allez
vous allez avec sa générer une
croissance instantanée de un ennemi 2 %
etc
mais c'est c'est lamentable d'ailleurs
que vous ne pouvez pas imaginer que ce
truc là tiennent advitam eternam donc
surtout que eux pour le coup ils ont pas
des taux à 0,1
ils ont des taux qui sont à 2,8 hectares
donc quand vous avez une telle dette et
avec un taux d'intérêt qui est ce qu'il
est mais qui est en tout cas supérieure
à la croissance
ça peut pas fonctionner si lieberman
vous êtes d'accord on n'en sort pas
l'endettement
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait mettre en place
pour ce qu'il faudrait mettre en place
ça moi je donne plutôt une stratégie
d'évitement c'est à dire pour les
conseils paris particulier c'est à dire
il faut sortir de cette fin il faut
mettre le moins possible dans le circuit
bancaire parce que comment la crise va
se manifester on sait pas ça peut être
une vague d'inflation sa patte une vague
de faillites bancaires
ça peut être bon c'est pas trop mais
disons qu'à au moment où ça arrivera il
faut pas avoir trop d'argent à la banque
voilà donc il vaut mieux sortir et aller
vers des actifs réels donc on à paris
millier mais s'est un peu bu l'air il ya
aussi l'or physique ou le bitcoin ou des
choses comme ça voilà mes oeuvres d'art
voitures de collection mais ça c'est des
marchés complexes
je veux connaître la paix disons couette
mais tous ces marchés l'augmentent tout
où s'est produit la voient leur valeur
augmenter le marché de l'art le water
collection tout ça et ça ça indique que
les gens ont quand même une crainte
vis-à-vis de la monnaie et se disent on
va se mettre de plus en plus sur les
choses concrètes et réelles qui qui qui
tiendront le choc en cas en cas de crise
voilà juste pour terminer est ce qu'un
état peut faire faillite ou même titre
qu'une entreprise ou qu'un ménage
il peut faire défaut mais un grand pays
c'est un grand pays fait défaut le
problème c'est qu'ils se met au ban des
nations parce que la france a beaucoup
de
de relations internationales c'est pas
possible de dire si on dit au qatar on
revoir depuis la dette qu'on a le qatar
va dire je vais saisir les airbus d'air
france qui à l'aéroport enfin voilà on
rentre dans des logiques comme ça qu'ils
sont qui sont extrêmement néfaste pour
équipe provoquer un défaut devant du
commerce international donc il vaut
mieux que l'état puisse gérer ça mais
bon la commande à un peu dépassé les
limites ça va être compliqué décidément
le coronavirus ne nous laisse aucun
répit
en plus de faire peur au monde entier ce
sont maintenant les marchés qui en
pâtissent le plus
le 9 mars restera comme un lundi noir
aucune pitié
les bourses des différents pays
s'effondre et on prédit une croissance
fortement ralenti un peu partout tout le
monde attend maintenant les mesures des
banques centrales pour une fois de plus
maintenir l'économie à flot tant bien
que mal la fed la réserve fédérale des
états unis a déjà baissé ses taux d'un
demi point et la banque centrale
européenne bas compliqué de baisser des
taux qui sont déjà au plus bas à l'heure
où on fait ce tiroir cash on ne sait pas
encore ce qu'elle va faire mais on
imagine bien christine lagarde nous
sortir une politique
whatever it takes à la mario draghi au
ps christine lagarde elle va nous
intéresser celle là c'est sûr à la garde
adhémar de trop et le 9 mars ce sont les
cours du pétrole qui a enregistré leur
plus forte chute depuis 1991 et la
guerre du golfe après que l'opep et la
russie n'ait pas réussi à s'accorder sur
une baisse de la production pour limiter
les dégâts face à la baisse des
transports bref ce coronavirus déclenché
un vrai choc économique attendait c'est
que des baies
on n'a pas fini certains économistes
parlent déjà de crise financière ou de
krach boursier
le corps n'avait rien tant m
on a un coronavirus qui révèle une crise
de fond une crise structurelle sur les
marchés financiers et la moindre le
moindre problème sur un marché réel le
moindre problème économique qui laisse
penser qu'ils vont avoir une récession
va entraîner un entraîne actuellement le
bouleversement qu'on observe on a
assisté à un arrêt des échanges à wall
street
pouvez nous parler d'eux
cette situation qui est très rare oui
c'est pas anodin en principe quand ça
arrive c'est que vraiment on s'attend à
une panique absolue sur un marché alors
les dernières fois que c'était arrivé
c'était moins grave parce que c'était
simplement des bottes des algorithmes
qui s'était un peu monté le bourrichon
entre eux et qui du coup faisait
exploser des prix donc on a tout calmé
mais là on sait que ce sont des humains
qui s'inquiètent et donc on sait qu'il
ya une vraie panique parce que au fond
personne n'est dupe tout le monde sait
qu'il ya un vrai problème sur les
marchés et j'irai encore plus loin que
ce que vous disiez au début je pense
même pas que ce soit 2008 sa date de
2000 et on vit toujours sur la crise
internet de 2000
allez vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui là
après moi je veux on pourrait remonter
aussi à ltcm 90 sion dès que ça c'est à
dire que depuis ce moment là on a des
banquiers centraux qui ont dit ne vous
inquiétez pas nous vous assurons donc
évidemment si vous voulez cesser on peut
faire une métaphore là dessus s'est
expliqué que vous faites du trapèze
volant vous avez affilée vous pouvez
faire le con autant que vous voulez
parce que vous savez que vous allez
tomber dans le filet si jamais ça se
passe mal si on vous avait dit à ce
moment-là j'ai cas il n'y a pas de filet
là vous y réfléchissez à deux fois avant
de faire votre saut périlleux parce que
vous savez que si vous vous raté ses
parterres et bien c'est exactement la
même chose au moment de 98 commandes
ltcm greenspan arrive et dit ne vous
inquiétez pas papa est là avec son gros
chéquier et il va régler tous les
problèmes et à partir de ce moment là
vous avez les banquiers qui se disent on
a carte blanche parce que toute façon
quoi qu'on fasse comme bêtises on à la
banque centrale qui est derrière et qui
va régler nos problèmes et donc là on
est parti dans quelque chose qui était
complètement débridée avec des gens qui
vous utilisez des effets de levier
énormes en se disant mais toute façon si
on se casse la gueule c'est pas grave
parce qu'il y aura quelqu'un pour payer
la casse et c'est vrai que au final
c'est un modèle magique
1 parce que
fâcheux gagnent pile tu perds donc au
final je suis toujours gagnant je me
réparti grassement les gains et quand il
ya des pertes c'est mutualisé c'est le
contribuable qui paye donc on peut pas
rêver mieux comme modèle économique
sauf que évidemment il ya des moments où
ça commence à coincer et là on est à un
moment où ça commence à coincer parce
que c'est pas fini
on a notre secrétaire d'état à
l'économie qui mardi nous disait
investissez dans les actions
on sait déjà pris 15% depuis c'est
merveilleux ces gens qui savent ce qui
ce se croient des traders et si on sait
ce que je vous disais c'est que une
récession normale c'est 40 % sur un
marché donc une récession plus
importante mondial avec très
probablement des choses qu'on ne connaît
pas c'est ce que je vous disais on n'a
jamais vu un pays qui était arrêté la
production et la séance hier en italie
notamment baissé énormément les
évidemment les onze c'est ce que je dis
on va le tarif qu'on va être obligé de
payer probablement bien plus élevé que
30 ou 40% et que on a et à ce moment là
il faut voir les conséquences que ça va
avoir sur les assureurs sur les
banquiers etc sur les fonds de pension
des reculs comme ça de 40 ou 50 % alors
que ces entités là ont mis du risque
dans leurs portefeuilles parce qu'elle
n'avait plus rien en terme de rendement
sur les obligations
donc elles sont elles sont allées
chercher du risque et aujourd'hui vous
voyez ce que ce que donne le risque donc
ça va ça va faire des dégâts
on doit s'attendre à des faillites en
cascade parce que si le problème et
c'est ça qui va se passer c'est que on
s'aperçoit que des entreprises en fait
non pas les flux de trésorerie et non
pas les profits qu'ils étaient alignés
avec leurs niveaux de dette
de toute façon elles vont elles vont
couler et donc mécaniquement si ce sont
des grosses c'est une catastrophe
et ici il ya deux il ya de grandes
possibilités de toute façon sera un
effet domino mais pour comprendre ce qui
va devoir faire il faut se demander où
est ce que ça va commencer soit c'est
une très grosse boîte que tout le monde
pense est en très bonne santé qui
s'effondrent c'était bout d'autres comme
dans la crise de 2000 et c'est ça qui
déclenché la panique dans un secteur qui
contamine tout le reste soit et c'est
encore plus grave
ce sont ces sons des instruments
financiers que tout le monde considérait
comme très valorisant et est très
profitable et qui du jour au lendemain
en fait s'avère trop risqué et c'est le
cas aux états unis de ce qu'il remplace
un peu nos banques à nous ou nos
investissements institutionnels c'est le
cas des fonds indiciels où des gens
mettent vraiment leur argent pour payer
les crédits ensuite étudiants de leurs
enfants ou leurs retraites etc et là vu
que ça s'est alignée est indexé de façon
très passive sur le snpi samson ou sur
d'autres places boursières quand on va
s'apercevoir que sur ces places et une
incertitude
alors cessons là auront plus de valeur
et là c'est directement les peler les
particuliers qui perd de l'argent
donc évidemment mécaniquement ils
peuvent plus honorer non plus leurs
dettes donc les banques
elle aussi se retrouve en panne de
liquidités et là c'est la catastrophe on
va parler maintenant des réponses que
peuvent apporter les gouvernements et
les banques centrales je vous propose
d'abord de regarder ce tweet de donald
trump pour ceux qui parlent beaucoup sur
twitter alors je cite notre réserve
fédérale minable et lente alors c'était
le 10 mars dernier
c'est important de le préciser notre
réserve fédérale minable et lente dirigé
par jeff powell qui a relevé les taux
trop rapidement et baisser trop tard
devrait ramener notre taux directeur au
niveau de ceux de nos pays concurrents
ils ont maintenant un avantage allant
jusqu'à 2 points avec une aide encore
plus importante sur les devises olivier
comment vous interpréter ce message du
président américain
en fait ils lol il enfonce une porte
ouverte c'est à dire que aujourd'hui les
faut bien comprendre que les banques
centrales n'ont pas le choix l oms
en fait elles se sont lancées dans le
quantitative easing dans la planche à
billets à partir de 2009 et c'était
c'était le le des le des le premier jour
si vous voulez c'était trop tard on est
tombé dedans on est tombé dans un
système de drogue
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois votre
choix est simple quantative easing le
cantal ont cessé en or en fait c'est
faire fonctionner la planche à billets
pour aller acheter des obligations le
marché avec une idée derrière la tête
qui était de se dire si on rachète des
obliques sur le marché ça va permettre
aux banques qui vont avoir des
liquidités de les prêter alors ça c'est
toujours le grand truc c'est de se dire
que dans la halle la théorie économique
c'est c'est de se dire si les taux
baissent les entreprises vont emprunter
mais non moi je suis entrepreneur
si vous voulez vous pouvez me coller les
taux à zéro c'est pas pour ça que je
vais emprunter je vais emprunter si j'ai
des marchés je vais emprunter si j'ai
des clients j'ai fait emprunter si je
dois faire un investissement mais je
vais pas emprunter parce que les taux
sont passés de 3 c'est pas vrai et ça
n'existe dans aucun donc aucune
entreprise mais évidemment ces gens là
ceux qui sont à la tête des banques
centrales n'ont jamais géré d'entreprise
ils ont appris l'économie dans des
bouquins et malheureusement ça marche
pas comme dans le book
voilà un mot justement sur la banque
centrale européenne alors au moment où
on enregistre cette émission il vient
d'avoir quelques annonces de la bce qui
ont plutôt fait plonger encore davantage
les bourses européennes
un mot justement sur ces mesures qui
semblent avoir été prises dans un
premier temps peut-être que ça suivra
d'autres d'autres mesures 120 milliards
d'achats de dettes publiques sauf 120
milliards d'achats et de l'autre côté on
maintient des taux bas alors oui prêts
pour les pme de toute façon maintenant
coincé pour coincer on vit sous
perfusion de toute façon si vous coupez
la perte du jour au lendemain c'est
c'est fini donc ils sont coincés mais le
problème avec ça c'est que si on reste
dans cette logique
en fait ce qu'ils nous font c'est
exactement ce qui a toujours été fait et
ce qui est la cause profonde de la crise
et de nous dire il va falloir soutenir
la demande parce que c'est une crise de
demandes et on va inciter les gens à
s'endetter mais le coeur du problème
c'est la dette c'est qu'on vit on a vécu
au dessus de nos moyens parce que
l'argent est faux et en fait non
ce qui se passe sur les places
financières est ce que récupère les
entreprises n'a aucun rapport avec les
fondamentaux réel donc mécaniquement on
comprend qu'ils aient une inquiétude
c'est peut-être même un bon signe c'est
que les marchés se disent bon ben c'est
pas la bonne solution c'est pas ça qu'il
faut faire vous pouvez pas nous refaire
une forme de quantitative easing ou la
réinjection à la vague de monnaies parce
que finalement vous vous êtes juste en
train de créer une bulle alors soit
c'est pris comme ça et c'est bon signe
soit l'avenir nous dit qu'en fait c'est
qu'on attend encore plus et c'est très
mauvais signe ça veut dire qu'on a des
en fait des entreprises zombies que
comme on a au japon qui ne vivent que
grâce à de la dette et qui attendent
plus de dettes parce qu'il voit qu'avec
ce niveau-là ça suffira pas et là là
c'est très mauvais signe que je crois
aujourd'hui que les marchés attendent
réellement le signal que la banque
centrale est toute puissante et il
semble alors on pourrait dire en voyant
la baisse des cours que le marché a
compris qu'en fait la banque centrale a
perdu la main mais je j'ai peur quand
même que ce soit l'un la deuxième
opposition c'est à dire que le marché 10
mhz en face c'est inadmissible elle n'a
pas baissé les taux en même temps et
c'est alors qu'on s'attendait à des
mesures encore plus fortes
on s'attendait en gros à ce que madame
lagarde disent à écouter s'il faut 1000
milliards pour remonter bas on mettra
1000 milliards s'il en faut 5 milles on
en mettra cinq mille c'est ça qu'ils
attendraient pas le chercher ce qui
n'est pas le cas mais vous inquiétez pas
ça va venir c'est à dire que dans les
semaines à venir si on continue sur ce
rythme là il est évident que vous allez
avoir une action concertée des banques
centrales qui vont vous dire écoutez
voilà on est là nos limites comme
l'avait dit draghi nos limites
s'il faut cinq mille milliards on mettra
cinq mille milliards s'il en faut dix
mille on en mettra dix mille parce que
au final vous n'avez pas de formules
mathématiques qui vous disent à partir
d'un certain taux à ceux ci de là de la
banque centrale va à partir d'un certain
montant de bilan de la banque centrale
la monnaie ne vaut plus rien donc c'est
juste une crise de confiance et on ne
sait absolument pas quand la confiance
va disparaître et donc au final pourquoi
pas avoir un bilan de banques centrales
et gallo pib de la zone
plus haut que le pib de la zone parce
que vous sortez dans la rue ou prenez 10
personnes vous leur dites demain le
bilan de la banque centrale européenne
les phases de 4700 à 10000 milliards
je doute que les gens se roulent par
terre en crise d'épilepsie 1
ils vont vous dire bah oui et alors bon
voilà donc que ça passe
le les banques centrales le savent et
donc elles vont en profiter
les déjà dit plusieurs fois mais une
récession normale
c'est quelque chose qui coûte entre 30
et 40 % sur 1 sur un marché par rapport
à ses à ses niveaux d'avant le sait plus
haut qu'on a touché il ya quelques il ya
quelques semaines seulement et
et là vous avez constaté qu'à peu près
tous les marchés dans le monde avait
baissé entre 30 et 40% très proche de
40% 38 pour les états unis
pareil pour chez nous et donc vous avez
donc mis le prix d'une récession normale
maintenant vous n'êtes pas dans une
récession normale vous êtes dans une
récession hors norme
vous avez vu que récemment les les
dernières indications sur les les
indemnités chômage qui avait été demandé
aux états unis
on parle évidemment de la situation aux
états unis presque 2 4 millions c'est
quelque chose qui n'est qui est du
jamais vu vous aviez les pires
prévisions qui faisaient état d'un
million et demi de personnes qui
allaient s'inscrire donc vous en avez
plus du double ce qui veut dire que ce
qui veut dire qu'on va être dans une
récession monumental vous avez certaines
banques qui prévoit une récession de
jusqu'à 24% sur le premier trimestre
donc vous pensez bien qu'on ait quelques
dents quelque chose de hors norme
quelque chose de hors norme ça peut
valoir probablement 60 65 % sur un
marché aurait pensé de la mf l'autorité
des marchés financiers qui a interdit la
vente à découvert sur 92 titre à la
bourse de paris
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cette
initiative écoutez ça serait bien que la
mmf apprennent ce que c'est qu'un marché
financier ça serait utile visiblement
elle ne le sait pas ce qu'elle a fait
aurélien d'abord pas parce que ils sont
persuadés que évidemment si les titres
baisse c'est débile un vendeur à
découvert qui font qu'ils font les
baisses c'est idiot c'est simplement
aussi des gérants qui peut qui vendent
des titres et qui vendent des titres
qu'ils ont vous savez des gens qui
vendent à découvert des marchés y en a
pas énormément d'abord ça c'est une
première chose et la deuxième chose ce
qu'a fait la ms ne sert strictement à
rien parce que
dans la seconde qui suivait on pouvait
évidemment vendre à découvert toute la
liste qu'ils avaient publié c'était
assez simple en fait il suffisait de
vendre les futurs et d'acheter toutes
les études qui n'était pas dans la liste
et à ce moment là deux fêtes vous étiez
vendeur sur la sur la lys donc c'est
idiot ça ne sert à rien c'est juste de
la com et ça prouve une bonne chose
c'est que les gens qui travaillent à la
mf ne sont pas au courant de ce que
c'est qu'un marchés financiers alors
parmi les réponses qui ont été apportées
par les banques centrales et les
gouvernements
il ya ce chiffre plus de 5000 milliards
de dollars c'est ce qu'ont promis
d'injecter les vingt premières
puissances économiques le g20 elles ont
promis d'injecter dans l'économie à
travers notamment des politiques
fiscales ciblées des mesures économiques
et des plans pour contrer les impacts
sociaux économiques et financiers de la
pandémie olivier est ce que c'est une
réponse qui est à la hauteur de la
gravité de la situation
c'est ce que je vous ai toujours dit
c'est-à-dire que le jour où il y aurait
un problème sur les sur les marchés ce
qui est le cas le jour où il y aura un
problème sur les marchés ça serait
carnet ou erp open bar open bars des
banques centrales c'est ce qu'ont mené
ce à quoi on assiste depuis quelques
quelques semaines où on voit que les
banques centrales ont en gros annoncé
que quel que soit le coût elle et elle
essaierait de tenir les marchés donc on
est en train si vous voulez de ce
japonisé au niveau des banques centrales
et pareil pour les annonces économiques
des gouvernements
ces carnets ouvert c'est-à-dire on se
fiche complètement de savoir combien ça
va coûter cette histoire
on s'endette comme jamais donc ne vous
faites aucune illusion
ça vous reviendra dans la figure au
niveau des impôts